on hopeful advice with Bobby at kalila
uh this is from Bob
hi Bob you Island Gilbert I am 21 year
old guy from Canada I'm sort of a new
listener but I grew up watching MADtv as
a kid
now here's my problem as of last year I
became wheelchair-bound but my whole
life I've been relying on stand-up so I
wasn't stressing over what to do with my
life but now I don't have any confidence
left
I booked a gig at Amateur Night and got
cold feet and backed out because I kept
feeling I would get pity laughs it just
freaks me out that people might only
laugh out of pity and out of my calm
okay he's got a wheel cheese
wheelchair-bound
wheelchair the rest of his life yes okay
I wanted I hadn't know exactly what to
say city feels lost yeah okay
when I started in San Diego the manager
of the Comedy Store was a guy by the
name of Fred burns he had spinal bifida
thank you spinal bifida and he had
crutches in a wheelchair couldn't walk
crutches on a wheelchair yeah the double
thing which is very difficult to move
[Laughter]
yeah so um but he was voted that the
funniest comic in San Diego many many
years in a row very funny guy one-liners
there's another guy named cringe Fonseca
he lives in Colorado I don't know what
the [ __ ] he is I mean he literally can't
he just lays down on a thing and he
can't move his arms or his legs so they
just put the mic to his mouth oh I think
that's what Stephen Hawking says which
is [ __ ] and then there have been a
lot of people generative you know I know
comics they have arm missing you know
and it's like you can do a couple of
minutes on it but if you can somehow
just do you know get people on your side
by saying some sort of self-doubt
occasion like you know Fred's opening
love I can't dance you know or something
like that why you were like laughing
whatever and so I would do it because I
know like Kris Fonseca you know he's on
television and he's done a bunch of
stuff you know and people she's sure you
know maybe some people though he's just
trying to get penny laughs or whatever
but listen I'm like I can walk but you
don't think that I get pity laughs I
know we're looking to dude I rely on
that you know it's like not all my whole
act is about my body or the way I look
but I don't feel I feel like I'm a
handicap also and I feel like it's your
dream do it because no matter even if
you're like handsome white dude you're
still gonna get Chris's criticism you're
never gonna escape criticism so do it
there's really no yes no other really
there's no joke to it I'm just saying I
can't even believe that you would email
us about that if it's something that you
truly desire whether it's carpenter or
engineering or comedy if that's what you
want to do wheelchair or not just
[ __ ] do it
and pity it let's suppose you get pity
laughs once in a while and when you get
good you're not it that's not that's not
gonna be the case just get good and also
it's it's not because you it's fear it's
the fear of failing it's not the feel
fear of being perceived a certain way
because it's it will it be harder to do
maybe but that's what the fear is I
think right also consider the fact that
this is a 20 year old kid who now who's
been walking and his whole life who's
been mobile his whole life let's
consider the fact that all of a sudden
he no longer has use of his legs and
that transition alone even just
psychologically without comedy aside
psychologically emotionally that has to
be a heavy burden to carry the thought I
mean just
you at 20 think about it for yourself so
I think that you know what I hear in the
email is not the question of what can I
do
I think I'm reading like a sense of like
sadness like an almost like desperation
or fear that maybe he can't he doesn't
feel like he can do it no you're gonna
do it but he you're gonna and you're
gonna do it that's okay I'm gonna go
you're gonna do it
listen what's his name Bob Bob if you
don't do it you're a [ __ ] you kind of
you're gonna do it and you're gonna get
good at it and that's all I'm gonna say
about it
[Music]